this week on wheel of science we're
talking
space death or apocalypse wow
chuck there's no end of ways to die in
space this is why i keep my black behind
right here on earth
welcome to wheel of science
hello hello hello welcome to wheel of
science i'm your host chuck nice
this is the interactive show where we
answer your questions about the universe
but i don't answer your questions about
the universe the one
the only the inimitable dr neil degrasse
tyson answers your questions about
science what's up neil i'm doing good
chuck
uh hailing from my office at the
american museum of natural history
right here in new york city do you ever
go home i mean seriously do you ever go
home
my home is the universe so wherever i am
i'm home
i don't think your family would
appreciate that answer
all right neil what time is it it's time
to play wheel of science
you heard the man spin that wheel
[Music]
michael gordon wants to know will our
son go nova or
supernova asking for a friend
you lying
uh the sun will do neither
neither the sun is not that kind of star
the sun as it gets older
and wiser it will ultimately exhaust the
fuel in its core
and one of the things that goes on
inside
is that it begins sort of converting
hydrogen into helium
in an outer shell that works its way
it's no longer doing it in the core
it's this shell that works its way out
and while it's doing that
the sun will bloat and get huge
and it will engulf the orbit of mercury
then
venus then it'll render earth's oceans a
boil
they will then evaporate into the
atmosphere earth's atmosphere will
evaporate into space
as we lose our orbital stability and
descend
into the stellar abyss vaporizing
along the way have a nice day
well neil you should really write
children's books
there you go michael i hope you're happy
you killed us all all right neil you
ready for another question
spin that wheel
here we go dorothy wiseman wants to know
how big of an asteroid
would it take to totally destroy the
earth
sometimes when people say destroy earth
they mean destroy life on earth
and all that takes is an asteroid 10
miles across that'll do it
because you don't have to kill everybody
well yeah you'll kill anybody who is
where you hit
all right they're gone instantly but
then how about everybody else
well since we all eat off of one another
if you take out the base of the food
chain because you've cloaked the earth
in darkness from this asteroid impact
then that takes out the plants
and if you take out the plants you take
out the animals that eat the plants then
you take out the animals that eat the
animals that eat the plants
and this is a wave of extinction that
percolates across the tree of life
10 miles across would do it the one that
took out the dinosaurs was about the
size of mount everest about six miles
across
if you want to obliterate the entire
earth there is no such object out there
to do so
cool i mean that not cool that's not
cool
will it make a difference where that
10-mile asteroid will hit oh
it won't make any difference at all
we're talking about how much energy is
being plunked down onto earth's surface
and it's an energy calculation at that
point it doesn't matter it hits land or
ocean doesn't matter we think something
hits the ocean we
the way we normally want to think about
it is there's a tsunami and the tsunami
is bad
if you're 10 miles across
you are bigger than the depth of most of
the world's ocean
so the ocean it just doesn't even matter
you're making a crater in the bottom of
the ocean
when you hit so no this doesn't matter
kiss your ass goodbye you know what i
love about this episode it's
so uplifting which is why we're going to
take a break while i contemplate my own
death
we'll be right back even after the
apocalypse
you'll want to have a website and you'll
want to create that site on wix
wix is what i use to make
wheelofscience.com you'll be spending
your time running from an asteroid or
fending off zombies so you'll want to
conserve your time and energy by using
the wix drag and drop
website builder upgrade to a premium
plan and you can get your own website
domain name
right away go to wix.com go slash star
talk
and begin your site now
welcome back the wheel of science what's
up neil are you ready for your next
question
chuck spin the wheel
nagor drak wants to know what's the most
realistic way that space could kill us
i like that okay if the sun
begins to misbehave we expect that to
happen in about 5 billion years
there will be considerably more solar
storms considerably more
and intense radiated particles emanating
from the sun
as that happens it will begin to ablate
our atmosphere
and basically taking out the highest
level
layers of the atmosphere systematically
as it continues to do this atmospheric
pressure will drop
we will have less and less air to
breathe as this process continues
and eventually we'll have no air to
breathe
at all and unless we become fish
real fast we get to breathe the
remaining air that's dissolved in the
ocean but that'll go away too
all the fishes will die and
when that happens we all suffocate
that space killing us in a diabolical
way
and it's space finally making aquaman
the preeminent superhero
chuck you know another way for space to
kill us what so if there's a gamma-ray
burst that happens a little too close
will happen is the high energy radiation
hitting earth
will first hit the ozone layer that's
our first line of protection right there
ozone takes out the x-rays and the
ultraviolet but then
there's so much of it the ozone layer
will not have a chance to recover
and so it's just waves and waves of
radiation
until the entire ozone layer is gone
and the next wave of that high energy
radiation then reaches earth
giving everyone skin cancer some people
skin cancer sooner than others
i'm pretty sure i'm in the later
category
all right it's caption time where we
took a picture of you neil and of course
ask for captions so can i offer my own
caption
go ahead back up i'm about to drop some
science on you
all right well let's see how that stacks
up against the winner elaine
ricklin who said this i should not
have had three tacos for lunch
i can't argue that one that's a good one
hey it's time for this week's poll
how would you like the cosmos to kill us
would it be
the expansion of the sun meteor
impact or gamma radiation
i'm going with gamma radiation because
it turned me into the black hulk
yes neil do you have any preferences
i think about this all the time if i
were to go rather than getting hit by a
bus or dying from cancer or
so many other sort of ways to go i want
to be
swallowed by a black hole in fact let
the black hole swallow all of earth that
would just be
talk about how to use the word awesome
correctly that would be awesome
something wrong with you man hey look at
that we're out of time
as always we have to say thank you to
neil degrasse tyson thanks neal i'm here
for you at arms reach whenever you need
me chuck
kind of sounds like you don't like me
but you know what i
i appreciate it anyway neil as always i
bid you
to keep looking up we'll see you next
time
okay so now you know how space is going
to kill you but we're at least a few
years away from that
why not spend the end of days with a
beautiful website you created on wix
you'll still have time to feed you and
your family so you can use the wix
website builder to manage your business
add an online store
add a blog and optimize for search
engines so all your living humans can
find your stuff
it automatically makes you a mobile site
and
you can modify it in a mobile editor or
personalize it even more
how cool is that
go to wix.com go slash star talk
and begin your site now trust me
even a comedian can do it and believe me
i did
[Music]
you